voodoo あっん
ます
でございます
私は
半世紀近く
植物今タイトルになりましたように植物の命の営みに魅せられて研究を続けてきました
その私が今日皆様にメッセージとしてお伝えしたいことは
6物は動けないのではなく動かなくても生きていけるから動かない
ということです
1981年に福井県先生と一緒にノーベル化学賞を受賞なさったロードホーンマン先生
が
アメリカさーんてぃすという学術誌に
2003年のことですがこのように書かれました
明日麻痺プレイ晴子風間で international christian
university in 統計
生
乱世さナッティコース there びびてぃ
あるかなん
by くりコースで羽生サーチへ来ずメーカーに住ん
ns ポーン today バルーン2
税という名のほうがいい
これが今日私がお伝えしたメッセージです
これからお話しすることは時間が限られているのであまり詳しお話はできないんです
けれども
植物のいたナビを
個以上に共有させていただいて皆様に今日はその意識感覚をぜひしていただきたいと
思います
植物は実にダイナミックに生きています
トマトご存知でいらっしゃいますか私を食べました皆さん全員
トマトを知ってるグッドボタンになると思うんですが
実は
私の共同研究者であったをすれ区立大学のブライアンファニング先生が取られた
動画お目にかけたいと思いますここにレールのように見えているのが
私たちの筋肉の構成成分の一つであるアクチンという繊維のところをこの一生懸命動い
ているのは
エネルギー源人
木をしているミトコンドリアなんです
これ早めているんじゃないんですよこれぐらい
アクティブに
卵ごめんなさいとマントはもしなまで3社が入ったら皆さんのお口の中で白はの所
踊り食いよりはるかにアクティブにごめんです
でそれは決してトマトだけではなくて次にお目にかけるのは
距離です
これは私が卒論の指導をしていた時に
顕微鏡で動画を撮る指導したんですがその時に撮影したものです
これも本当にキュウリなまでメジャーだったらお口の中でさっきのトマト盗んだ子を米
入っています
きゅうり後右手だけではなくて
きっとう代の頃に玉ねぎが転がってるんじゃないかと思いますがあの玉ねぎを向いて
顕微鏡主たでご覧になった
それもまたうごめいています
さらに植物は光合成が思っているので独立栄養を営むことができるので動かなくても
いいわけですがそれだけではなくて自分を守ることができます
その例を今方お目にかけたいと思います
よくホテルのロビーなどに見られるディフェンバキアという太陽植物があります
これはちょっとかじってみたりするとこの針みたいに出てるのは
しゅう酸カリウムというものの針状結晶です
ここに葉緑体な見える
葉っぱなんですよね
この8版の横にこんな特別な細胞があってそこから
かじられたらそれが刺激になって
ひゃあああっあんっ
春よ
だしていきますそうすると例えばおいしそうだなと思ってかじった動物の下を刺します
から
動物は食べるのをやめますこうして植物は自分の身を守る術を持っているわけです今お
話したように
植物は光合成能を持っているので独立営業員とな
ことができるこれは動物でも皆さんゾウリムシって顕微鏡の人でご覧になったことで
あるでしょうか
もうドライどころがないほどかーっ
やって動いてるんですねところが
クロレラを
強制させているゾウリムシと同じようなものに
乱れ虫があります
とミドリムシは
なんとゾウリムシの読むには
せわしなく動くことなく光合成をすることによって差を追いかける必要がないから
でしょう
緩慢な運動をしています
それなもう一つ
とても皆さんに良い例になるかなという例を多めにかけたいと思うんですが
ウミウシってご存じだと思いますいろんなを見牛がいますけれどもある種のウミウシに
これは2000年にアメリカの学術誌のプランピスをロジーという雑誌に
ノンタ論文なんですが
ウミウシにある緑藻類を食べさせていると海や氏はもともとはこういう細長い
私なのに葉っぱのような形を
つ繰り返してなおかつ
高剛性ができるのでエサを食べる必要がない
そのために口もた生かして攻撃脳も必要なくなりますから
角も退化してしまう
それでアメリカは早速緑の2を作ろうというプロジェクトを開始しました
まだ成功はしてないでしょうけどエサをやらなくても済む
豚を飼うことができるだろうと言って始めた研究プロジェクトです
さらに植物は自分の置かれた状況を知ることができます
一体自分は目を出してもいいんだろうか
芽を出して独立栄養営む条件が備わってるんだろうかっていうことを知らなければなり
ませんそれには植物は常緑も感知することができる仕組みが備わってますしいろいろな
仕組みがあるんですが今日は時間が限られ
れていますので光の鈴をお目にかけたいと思います
2人は植物にとって最大の市駅
どんな刺激かというと例えば光合成をするのに必要な二酸化炭素の取り入れ口の
孔辺細胞を着込むの孔辺細胞も光があってはじめて
作り出されるそれも一瞬光で作り出すそれぐらい大きな刺激を持っています
これで見ると私たち人が
城倉の識別ができる光の量の1/1000の光の量
ここで見えが見えるなんて言ってるよりも7-1も暗い光の量で植物はそれを感知して
成長するのをストップします
さらに趣旨はどうして本当にさっきもし
されたように発芽してもいい場所なんだろうか
発芽しても良いときなんだろうかということをするんでしょうか
光発芽種子は自分の置かれた位置を知る仕組みを持っています
太陽から来るかしこ7色ですね
それが
葉っぱを通ると機能したの
寿司のところに届く光というのは葉っぱが青怒り
赤い光光合成に必要なのは席職工と生殖孔ですがそれを吸収してしまいますからその下
に来るのはこんな光だけ
そうすると
葉っぱのフィルターを通り子通り抜けた光には
光発芽種子ば反応しなしたがって発芽の抑制が起こります
さらにこれは今日せっかくキャンパスにいらしているので御懐妊でも見て頂きたいと
思って
まだ解明されてない事柄なんですがご紹介したいと思いました
これは
研究棟と言われたたものがありますがその
前に終わっているカイヅカイブキという植物です
よくご覧になると緑色のところになんか白っぽい花見えますね
これを大きく伸ばしてみるとじつはカイヅカイブキの葉
ではなくてそれの元首になり当たる
次のような葉っぱが出てきていますいわゆる
鮮度が息が起こってるらしい
これは選定を行うために
あっ選定されたそこずにとっては来られたということですか
これは先祖開業しなきゃって思っているらしい
これは学習総合センターという所総合センターというところにある
海辺たい風景ですけどほとんど
ご覧になるのに次の葉っぱになってここにかろうじて
本
カイヅカイブキの歯が見られます
ところでこういう現象は
実はカイズカイブキだけではなくて一応っていうのはや絶滅危惧種に
と言われています
もう
中世第二高に横線年ぐらい前にはだけれども今はほとんど
園芸種として育てられているものです
その葉っぱを見るとキャンパスにも沢山ありますが
東京都のマークでもここに銀合意ピロー by ぷとぅ
学名にもあるように2つの幸
てっぺんって言ったら良いんでしょうか避けたところがあって
真ん中に一つ切れ目が入っているのにすぐそこの30m 道具
東八道路って言いますそこねチャオみるとこんな風にすごい切れ目が入ってるんですよ
キャンパスが1オーナーは本来の
の形なんだろうか
植物にとっての政府環境がとってもいいから
その予算をの方っているんだろうか
ところが
そうではなくて
私の代わりに植木屋さんが実験してくれたんですが2005年にん
初めて剪定をしました銀杏
きっと翌年はキャンパスのイチョウも
あのー
東八道路と同じように切れ込みが入るだろうなと思った
安の所2006年にはこういうふうに切れ込みが入ったキャンパスの利川でるんでした
23年経つと元に戻るんですか
さあ
これが東八道路の一応ですが
実はヨーロッパにことにドイツ今井町博物館というのがあるんですが
いろいろ化石が残っていますこれはジュラ紀の
う鳥の化石ですけど昔のイチョウはこんな風に切り込みが入っているんです
一体ナビがスイッチを
先祖返りの水鳥をしてるんだかそれ私の研究課題でもあった
エチレンという機体ガスが実はあっ来られたと思ったら
エチレンを出してこんな派遣を形作っているのではないかと推測されているところが
ある人分
ん
街路樹に大体こういう形のものが多いわけですけれども
ええっ
それは信号機が見えなくなると困るから毎年毎年選定しているんですねだからこんなに
なる
ところがある新聞有名な新聞ですけれども
街路10人目木を植えると銀杏は臭いから
あの
切れ込みが入っているのは遅咲きだ
メスの気は東京都のマークのような気だって誠シアターに新聞で紹介されていました
真っ赤な嘘ですそういうことを皆さんもご自分の目で確かめて
本当なのかという問いを持ちながら植物を見ていただきたいと思います
さあ
今回のテーマははということなので最後に私の話としてちょっと擬人化した表現になり
ますが植物がどんなに
ばということを重んじているかを
一つの例でお話したいと思います
北欧な地方にはポプラ抜きが並木がありますがそこに行く9差になります
でゆきうさぎとポプラの関係で一つ
植物がどんな顔文字てるかをご紹介したいと思います
宇佐美は
立った立って言ってポプラは食べます
そうするとどうなるかっていうとしばらく食べてたら
ウサギはポプラを食べるのをやめてしまいます
お腹がいっぱいになったからやめたのかな
と思うとどうもそうではない
一体何が起きてるんだろう
実は
さっきエチレンということを申し上げましたがこの
ポプラを食べると
いう
ポプラは
危険信号であるエチレンガスを生成し始めます
傷ついたポプラ on
危険信号を出しているんです
何が危険信号として役立っているかといいますと実は
エチレンガスは支部の音であるタンニンの生成を促進するんです
うさぎの種類のはわかりますから
渋いと思って食べるの止めます
そしてエチレンは期待ですから
9食べられたところだけではなくて周りに広がってきますから当然
近隣のプラモ担任を生成しますので
ウサギが食べなくなります
単には今言ったように支部の成分です
そしてゆきうさぎやポプラを食べるのをやめる
ところがエチレンねー
機体ですけれども濃度勾配ここから発生してもだんだんだんだんとなりのもやっても
こっちの方に行ったら
エチレンは生成しないんので
生成ら一連の濃度が薄いので何が起こっているか担任の生成がないそうすると
雪うさぎは遠くのポプラは担任がないから
また食べることができるウサギは遠くのポプラをた子食べ始めます
もしも
私たち人が
そういう過ちに陥りがちなんですが自分の欲に任せてウサギは食べるだけ食べてたら
自分の
さずになる食料になるポプラは全滅してしまうでしょう
それをなんとポプラの方はポプラで
エチレンだして単元を作らせてウサギに食べさせないようにするということで
うさ下の食料を
維持することにも役立っている
そんなことが本当は地球上の生命活動で生命そそれぞれ動物も植物も互いにき小唄持ち
ながら
生態系と胸像
維持をしているのが本当は先生名現象の基本にあることだと思います
私たち人はどうやってそれを自分たちの課題として受け止めてこれから持続可能な世界
ということがとても大事な世界になりますが
植物のこのは大文字るシステムのようなことで動物と植物の胸像が地球の上で成り立っ
ているそのことに一つ
見習う0になるのではないかと思っ
ご紹介をしました
静聴ありがとうございましたそしてちょっと前だ
どうぞ私の話を聞いてスライドの中にいくつか
植物の写真を入れておきましたが一つでも植物を覚えてお帰りになって自分の足下の
身近な植物をじーっとご覧になってその植物とはを
共存してこの地球に生き続ける
人類でありたいという願いを込めて植物の命の営みをご自分たちのものとして合計県
くださいますように
足元ちょっと人と立ち止まって足元を眺めて言って
ここにこんなに命の営みがそして私たちは共存する地球の市民としてこれから生きて
いくんだということを
前のまさに今の生き方だと思いますけれどもそれをご自分の生き方として
今日から受け止めて歩んでいかれますこと
お願いというかお祈りしながらまた市農協の拙お話終わらせていただこうと思います
本当にご静聴ありがとうございました
dare